[Applause]
the american working class paid a very
large
price for enriching the rest of the
world
is there such a thing as a hundred
percent truth you can get a bloody long
ways by being honest
we really have no idea what they're
doing to us these aren't trivial
technologies you know
some of the belief system that we have
politically liberal or conservative
we're born with
it's not the fact that the conservatives
are right or that the liberals are right
they're both necessary
annoying as that is trigger warnings
clearly make things worse there's a lot
of latinos in the room here were you
trying to encourage us to go out there
and have 10 babies to try and
stay they will make 10 babies in a
heartbeat if you say that who had an
absolutely dreadful morning and is just
as
as can possibly be imagined
that's kind of what twitter's like
i'm not really accustomed to being
slower than someone else in the room
can't believe i said that actually i
actually can't believe i said that
you know you ain't seen nothing yet
david
[Music]
please stand up and put your hands
together and welcome to the stage
patrick beth david and jordan v peterson
[Applause]
[Music]
how you feeling first of all how you
doing not bad that's an impressive sound
system that's an impressive sound system
if you're up here it's a lot louder than
you think i know it's also allowed on
the other side so
how many of you here have read the book
uh read jordan peterson's book razean if
you've read his book
okay we made it the book of the month
last month so we had a lot of our guys
uh
read the book but before we get into it
obviously a lot of people know
uh because they've read about you or
watched you in different places
12 rules you have your rule number one
is stand up straight with your shoulders
straight
number two is treat yourself like
someone you're responsible for helping
three is befriend people who want the
best for you four is compare yourself to
who you were yesterday
not the useless person you are today do
not let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them
set your house in order before you
criticize the world
pursue what is meaningful not what is
expedient
tell the truth or at least don't lie
that's number eight assume the person
you're listening to know
something you don't be precise
in your speech do not bother children
while they're
skateboarding and last but not least
petty cat
when you encounter one in the street i
heard somewhere you said it was 40 rules
and you narrowed it down to 12. it was
originally 42 and i'm working on another
set of 12. so what was the cutoff like
what was number 13 that missed out was
it was like a battle for number two i'm
curious to know what number 13 was for
you
well um
i tried to pick a set that would make a
uh coherent narrative
and so it wasn't like the rules differed
in quality particularly i think they
were all worth
writing about but when you write a book
you want it to have a certain
internal consistency and so i went for
that a couple of the rules that
didn't make it were
be careful who you share good news with
that's a good one because you want to
share good news with people who are
going to be genuinely happy for you and
that's one way that you can identify
those people who are only on your side
[Applause]
there was a corollary to that which was
be careful who you share
bad news with because that's equally
tricky you know you
you you want someone who will listen to
you
when you're having trouble and allow you
your grief
uh especially if it's a consequence of
something tragic and
who won't try to one-up you you know
because often
when you're talking to people they'll be
thinking about what they have to say
that's
worse and that's not helpful if you need
a listening ear make one room in your
house as beautiful as possible
that's that's what i'm writing about now
i i talked a lot about already about the
necessity of cleaning your room
which is you know in some sense a
foolish piece of advice because it seems
so obvious but
it's not obvious at all and you'll find
if you try it especially if you're in a
household that's not very functional
that you'll
encounter obstacles that you couldn't
imagine existed
while you're trying to put your life in
order and
you can take your surroundings beyond
order and and and move towards beauty
and that's unbelievably useful because
while beauty calls people to their
higher being i would say and
to make friends with beauty is to
introduce yourself and introduce
yourself very carefully to one of the
mysteries of life that make it worth
living and so
those are a few of the rules that didn't
make the original cut but that
i'm still working on and still thinking
about i'm definitely looking forward to
reading the next book that you come out
with
those are very interesting rules
appreciate you for sharing it with us
thank you for sharing it with us
so so you know there's this saying
there's this saying that says
tough times produce strong men
strong men produce good times
good times produce weak men weak men
produce tough times yes if that's the
truth
which phase are we in today
well if you think about it historically
you have to say that we're in good times
i mean that doesn't mean everything
about the current times are good and
of course life is always tenuous and and
and difficult but
it's 1919 if you go back a hundred years
ago
imagine what the last five years would
have been like right
you would have been the entire world was
encapsulated in a terrible war the
trench warfare was absolutely brutal and
that was a five-year period and
then that was followed by the spanish
influenza which killed 120 million
people and
you know so i'd rather be here now than
there then by a substantial margin and
i think life is never easy uh even under
relatively positive conditions but
i would say that
it's very difficult to make the case
that we're not in good times and i
especially think that's true if you look
at the world
globally the american working class
and maybe the western working class in
general paid a very large price
for enriching the rest of the world
you know i mean china's come up in a
miraculous way in the last 40 years
south korea india
while the entire sub in all of southeast
asia and increasingly africa too because
the fastest growing economies in the
world and now in sub-saharan africa
and that's produced a tremendous
competition for working-class people in
the west
but speaking on a global level
there's never been a better time for the
majority of people
to be alive and the future
although we're vulnerable and terrible
things can always happen to us
it's hard to make a case that the future
doesn't look
comparatively positive we're becoming
extremely
technologically um sophisticated
and the world is changing at an
incredibly rapid rate and
the only way we're going to be able to
manage that in a positive way is if
each of us or as many of us as possible
are capable of making
wise and careful and truthful decisions
and if we do that then
you know maybe things can continue to
improve
um the rate of absolute poverty in the
world has
fell fell by 50 between the year 2000
and the year 2012.
you know that's the fastest rate of
economic improvement in the history of
the world and
and um there's plenty of reason to be
optimistic um if you're inclined in that
direction
uh i would say it's best to marry that
with a healthy dose of
attentive caution because well as i said
things can go badly wrong but i can't
think of a time
in the past that i would trade for now
despite all the problems that are
also part and parcel of being alive now
so do you think
these good times will produce weak men
or you don't buy that you think
in any times we're going to have weak
strong people being produced well i
think
i think there is a certain danger in
in luxury you know we don't know
how necessary a certain degree of
privation is
to motivation you know the typical
first generation immigrant story is
someone arrives with nothing and this is
motivated fully to do what is ever
whatever is necessary
to make either themselves or their
children a success
and that does seem to uh decline that
motivation does seem to decline
somewhat over the following generations
so for example asian immigrants um
their children outperform american
children in school by a substantial
margin
but that disappears by about three
generations that advantage
wow that disappears in three generations
yeah yeah as the as the asian
immigrants become more americanized
their proclivity to
um excel understand that concept
powerful so i come first generation i'm
more disciplined
my kid becomes less disciplined my
grandkids become less disciplined and
the one
prior to that you know past that also
gets less disciplined yeah well
like i said i mean and you probably face
this to some degree because
you know you have a lot of resources at
your command it's
very difficult to provide your children
with
optimal um privation
in order to make them to make them stand
on their own two feet
you know and you you don't get people to
stand up on their own two feet and to
adopt responsibility
if everything is given to them and that
that's that's a real conundrum
[Applause]
it's a real conundrum as you become
successful because
you're in a situation where if your
children ask you for something
there's no formal reason for you to say
no
you know because you can provide
whatever is being
requested but by doing that
you steal from them the opportunity to
generate
that for themselves and that's i suppose
one of the dangers of
well it's the one of the dangers of
prosperity what that does to people
over the long run i don't think we
understand well yet because
most people haven't been prosperous for
a very long right there's been plenty of
privation to go around and
of course there still is in many many
parts of the world including in the
united states and in the west
do you think we're getting softer and
more sensitive do you think in general
especially america because america has
been successful now for
quite some times we're constantly
growing do you think we are becoming
softer and more sensitive
well i think there's a push in that
direction like
there certainly seems to be a technical
push in that direction in the
universities
why well it's complicated you know
my like generally when i try to assess
something like that
there's a rule if you're a social
scientist and the first rule is
in some sense to look at context before
you look at personality
and i think there's been a lot of really
radical changes
in our society in the last 50 years and
we don't understand their consequences
the most radical change is probably the
birth control pill
because it's provided women with
voluntary control over the reproductive
function
and that's a equivalent to a
a major biological mutation right it's
it's
it's it's consequence is virtually
incomprehensible
i mean partly one of the consequences is
is you know where you
where reliable birth control is provided
to women
first of all they immediately become
educated second
their economies tend to grow and third
the birth rate falls below replacement
and then all three of those factors are
monumental
you know so um perhaps especially the
third the falling of the birth rate be
below replacement which is the case in
virtually every country in the western
world except the united states
um
softness well look like
we don't know exactly what the optimal
conditions are
under which you toughen up let's say
most children now have older parents
right because people aren't having
children until they're in their 30s
and there's a big difference between
having a parent who's in his or her 30s
and having a parent who's in his or her
20s
that the 20 year olds are still kind of
like kids and they're
going to be more usefully neglectful
i would say well look
one one of the things we used to do with
my daughter when she was very little was
you know she was about a year and a half
is we'd we'd have her in a room alone
and
she would usually complain about that
for a few minutes
and then she'd find a way to amuse
herself you know she liked to take books
out of shelves and put them back in and
like if if you let her be get through
that initial bit
of misery then she would learn how to
regulate herself and and she got very
good at that
um and so that's a good example of minor
privation
having a positive influence but you know
children used to have multiple siblings
and
siblings toughen you up because there's
tremendous competition in families among
siblings and they had younger parents
who had fewer resources and
you know now parents are older first of
all and second
they're more resource rich and so
they're more likely to schedule their
children to death
in some sense to provide them with all
the opportunities that they feel would
be
useful and that's understandable and
plus because they have fewer children
each child is in some sense more
precious
you know not like if you have 10
children you don't love all of them but
you know there's 10 of them there's
there's only so much excess attention
that can go around
and they do a lot of socializing each
other rather than being socialized by
parents but if you only have one
child you know you're going to devote
all your resources to providing them
with absolutely everything you can
provide them with and
one of the dangers of that is that
you'll over protect them and you'll
provide them with too much
and we don't understand those dynamics
right we don't understand how
much you should stay hands off your
kids and let them go out there and make
their own mistakes and
and find their own way and and that's
that's
well that's tricky and and we're
ignorant about it
and so i think one of the consequences
of that is that we do have
a reasonable percentage of young
people maybe young adolescents the kind
that you hear about at university who
have been
over protected and over sched over
scheduled and
under challenged in some sense
we extend that over protection far
longer than is helpful
um you know it's hard though because
as i said when you have resources you
can use them
to make your children's lives let's say
easier but the question is like
do you really want to make the life of
someone you love easier
and that's a incredibly difficult
question
and it's tough because how do you you
know the whole thing is when your kids
go
kids friends go and say hey i heard your
mom and daddy are rich why isn't your
mom buying you this car why isn't your
dad buying you this car but
was your underlying message you
encouraging us because there's a lot of
latinos in the room here were you trying
to encourage us to go out there and have
10 babies is that is that what you're
trying to say
that kind of you're talking they will
make 10 babies in a heartbeat if you say
that
these are professionals that making
babies here
well my you know my wife and i had two
kids and
we didn't start late compared to most of
the people we knew i think
i think our first child was born when my
wife was 29
we certainly felt that we would have had
more children if we would have started
earlier
there's no doubt that and this is a very
important thing to know you know
there's not that many things in your
life that are
of central importance there's half a
dozen i would say
um there's your friends there's your
family
your intimate partner um
by family i mean your siblings and your
parents but then there's your children
there's your career there's your
educational trajectory
there's how you take care of yourself
and protect yourself from temptation and
what sort of useful things you do
in the time that you're not working but
you know children are a third of life
something like that maybe more and so i
would certainly
recommend that you don't miss it
um it's complicated because of course
now
in most situations both parents have to
work and
but it's always been complicated to
raise children they they take a
they're a long-term investment but
yeah right which is hard that's why it's
hard hard to even pay child care workers
right because
the payoff for having a child doesn't
occur until two decades later
sometimes sometimes four decades later
but it's not something you want to miss
that's for sure
because it's it's well
that's life you know there's
it's it's part of the human condition
and
and little children
pay you back immensely
if you have a good relationship with
them
you know if you're on their side
and encourage them because they're
an unconditional source of joy and love
powerful
you know the
the other thing i noticed that that you
should that
that you should all know is that um
as you get older
your family the family you've produced
becomes more and more important
you know so we teach young women in
particular
that the fundamental goal of their life
is going to be their career
and you know first of all most people
don't have careers they have jobs
and those are very different things but
you're not a very happy camper so to
speak if you're
45 and you have no one
and it doesn't go upwards after that
so don't miss it
so jordan follow up to that i got a
question for you
very good point follow-up to that with
you
is you know we can have president bush
here speak in
in the next two days i don't know when
he's speaking in the next two days but
he's speaking
i can't say because secret service told
me i can't give the specific time
everyone's trying to figure it out
i almost gave you the time some of you
guys are waiting for that
but you know why is it that so many
uh uh powerful political families
send their kids off to boarding school
and i don't know as a clinical
psychologist how much
research or how much of that are you
have you looked at with the
link to boarding school teaches
independence toughens them up a little
bit
the whole opportunity to have your kids
have a little bit more challenging times
for them to go through
what are your thoughts on boarding
school well i
i don't think that there's any evidence
that
there's not a lot of evidence that
school quality per se
is a determining factor in the outcome
of
educational processes that actually
seems to be a situation i mean there are
exceptions and
i'm certainly not trying to say that
every school is equal but
um a tremendous amount of what
determines whether or not a child is
successful at school is their
intelligence i mean you people all went
to high school
to junior high school i mean you know
that in a group of 30 kids there's
some kids that are so bright that they
figure everything out in
the first 15 seconds and there are other
kids who just can't get it no matter
how hard they try and that's one of the
really
catastrophic and built-in inequalities
in the world
generally in boarding schools because
wealth and
intelligence tend to be correlated which
is also something you'd expect right
you'd expect more intelligent people to
be able to make more money
or you'd certainly at least expect less
intelligent people to be able to make
less money
the schools are generally of the schools
generally produce
good outcomes but it's not obvious that
it's because of the schools
um for even and that this is true at
higher levels of education too to a
degree that people don't really realize
so for example
um at a university like harvard any of
the ivy leagues
it's very very difficult to get in
right so there's far more applicants
than there are positions and
they use the sat
as one of the entry criteria so you have
to have a very
high sat score and then generally you
have to be good at at least one or two
other things
to be considered and a very large
percentage for example of harvard
undergraduates and there's only about
four
four thousand of them so it's it's a
rather small school
um we're valedictorians of their class
they have very high sat scores and
the sat is a proxy for iq um the people
who administer the sat don't like to
admit that but there's absolutely no
doubt that it's the case because
any set of questions
that assess general knowledge and
problem solving ability
can you can derive an iq score from and
so
part of the advantage of hiring an ivy
league graduate isn't the fact that they
went to a high quality school
it's the fact that it was impossible to
get in and so the screening
has been done for the employee for the
employer
by the admissions process at the school
and the same thing is true of business
schools and the business the people who
run business schools know that is that
the primary um value that they offer and
again this is not the case with every
business school
is the fact that if you hire an mba from
their program and it's a very selective
program then you have a very high
probability of hiring someone who's
intrinsically intelligent and and
conscientious
and that's a great predictor those are
great predictors of long-term success
so and what would you expect in a
society that's essentially meritocratic
it's pretty straightforward to think
this through
not only should people who are faster
and smarter
be more productive especially if they're
hard-working but that's really what
you'd want is it isn't it i mean
how the hell do you want to set up your
society you want to set up your society
so that
incompetent people who do nothing
succeed that that
first of all that can't happen
so
you know and i i i should say i should
say
that i'm very aware of the unfairness
of a meritocratic society of its
intrinsic unfairness so
let me give you an example um
i i had someone write me the other day
he had listened to some of my lectures
on iq and he sent me his iq scores
and he was in the fifth percentile
which basically meant that 95 95
of the people around him were faster
cognitively than he was and you know the
the letter had
it wasn't very grammatically correct and
it wasn't very well written
although it was very sad and and he said
that
he had a very difficult time finding a
job and keeping one that he was
constantly frustrated and
and and and unnerved and
that's a terrible thing you know i'm
because it's not as if it's his fault
a lot of what constitutes your innate
cognitive ability or your cognitive
ability is
something that's really granted to you
by by fortune and fate
and i mean you can make someone stupider
but it's very difficult to make someone
smarter although hard work definitely is
a plus
people stack up at the bottom and it's
not easy to figure out
how to deal with that but because you
need
the people who are leading the cognitive
revolutions to
develop entrepreneurial enterprises and
to run things properly and to invent the
new things that we all use and
hopefully to raise the living standards
of society in general
so do you think uh you said it's
it's it's easier to make people stupider
that's what you said
it's easier to make people stupider oh
definitely well you can do that by
depriving of them depriving them of
nutrition when they're children
i mean one of the things we know and
this is from
bjorn lomberg's work which i would
really recommend lomberg has
put together a team of economists to
rank order
problems in the world by return on
investment
in in solving them so you imagine you
know maybe there's a hundred problems
that beset the world
from starvation to to lack of water to
lack of sanitary facilities to lack of
education
to tyrannical governance to well
you you can you can continue the list in
your own imagination
um what lomberg did was consult very
high level economists who he put in
teams to find out where you get the
biggest
return for your foreign policy dollar
over you know a reasonable stretch of
time and and
it's clearly the case that if you invest
in early childhood nutrition that that
pays off at about 250 to one
and so one of the ways that you can
impair children's intelligence
permanently is by ensuring that they
don't have enough to eat when they're
very young
and that's actually something that can
be addressed very inexpensively and
it's to everyone's benefit so
so that's one way you can make people oh
yes so let me ask you this
do you think uh uh do you think media
makes us
smarter or stupider um i think it makes
some people smarter and some people
stupider
i mean well look at television debate
see you you've got to kind of fragment
you've got to kind of fragment the
people that you're talking about into
different groups you know
it's like asking whether daycare is good
for kids or not
and the answer is if the daycare is
better than your family
then daycare is good for you
and
you know and i actually mean that
technically because the studies of
of early childhood day care indicate
that for some kids it's
it's it's perfectly fine and for other
kids it's not uh
it's good if your kid is extroverted and
ready to play with other children and so
forth there's a lot of individual
differences that
that have to be taken into account so um
media in general look imagine that
you're a little kid and
you know your parents are neglectful and
you're in your crib most of the time but
the television is on
well that's a hell of a lot better than
just being in your crib
you know and so it is pretty clear too
over the last century
on average iq levels have gone up by
quite a substantial amount
and the reason for that seems to be that
the very
low end has been pushed up and some of
that's going to be a consequence of
increased nutrition and some of it's
going to be a consequence of the fact
that
television is a lot better than nothing
like
infinitely better now whether television
is better for you than
you know a diet of of of high quality
literature that's a whole different
question
whether it's better for you than playing
properly with your peers
and engaging in pretend play and all the
other things that you have to do to
establish yourself
as a competent child that's also another
question
but generally speaking
i would say that the dispersion
of the media technology we have has made
us far more intelligent
and the other thing that's worth
thinking about too is that
computers also make us more intelligent
i would say
not because of the content but because
of the technology
you know you've got to be pretty damn
organized and sharp to keep your phone
and your computer working these are high
high maintenance gadgets you know and it
actually annoys the hell out of me
because
you know i was sort of old enough so
that computers came along
a lot of people my age aren't very good
at using computers
and and oh and people who are older are
even worse
i made a decision when the computers
started to become
omnipresent and so that would have been
about 1993
that i was going to spend a year and
that was the first year that i was
teaching in boston
pretty much doing nothing but figuring
out how
intel 486s worked and it meant there was
a lot of other things that i had to put
on hold but i did
become a competent computer user and i
was
i'm pretty fast but you know my son
it's just annoying as hell to watch him
on the computer and on the phone because
and my graduate students as well because
they're so much faster than me that it's
not even funny and i'm not really
accustomed to being
slower than someone else in the room and
so
um
you know it's
you know the the other thing you see too
is that
i mean uh certainly i would say if my
son
and and my daughter are both competent
technology users
my son in particular although my
daughter has her her
her shining spots too especially for use
of social media but
you know if i had children now the one
thing i would bloody well make sure that
they knew was how to use a computer how
to program man
because if you're smart and you can use
a computer you are so much smarter than
you are if you're just smart that it's
not even funny
you know when you talk to people you see
this in silicon valley all the time you
talk to people who are expert computer
users
they are so bloody powerful it is just
beyond belief
so and that that's going to do nothing
but expand right because moore's law is
not dead and
computers are doubling in power every 18
months and and so
and who the hell knows where that's
going to go so
your kids they should know everything
they possibly can about how to
spin a computer on their finger like a
basketball player
so is that one of the reasons why you
love twitter so much
well i had twitter
[Music]
i have um i have
pulled back from twitter almost entirely
in the last
four months and i can't say that that's
done me any psychological harm um
i've quit reading the comments they know
the comments on twitter are really
kind of they're they're such an odd way
of communicating because
let's say you tweet something out and
goes out to oh who knows
i think i have a million twitter
followers it's something like that
and i don't know how many of them read
what i tweet but let's say
10 000 or something it's just a guess
who who comments it's not like it's a
random sample
you know like if i just pointed to 50
people in the audience randomly and
asked for an opinion about something
i'd kind of get a good sample of what
the audience thought but if i said okay
who had an absolutely dreadful morning
and is just as
as can possibly be imagined okay
so why don't all you people stand up
okay
and then i'll ask the most miserable of
you for your opinion
that's kind of what twitter's like
you know so it's it's a form of pseudo
information
it's like you're communicating with
people and and you respond to it like
you're communicating with people because
well you're accustomed to communicating
with people and so that's how you
respond but
you don't know what the hell's going on
with the person who's commenting you
don't know if they
are even real if they're hiding behind
some false
pseudonym or if they're trolling or or
like i said if they just had an
absolutely miserable day and
need to you know throw a dart at someone
to alleviate some of their stress
so and it's a problem with social media
in general all these
new communication technologies that
we've evolved we we really have no idea
what they're doing to us they're really
really hard on young
women in particular facebook and
i mean you think about it you know when
i was a teenager
i mean i i did god if i had to write a
book about the stupid things i did
when i was a teenager it'd be a very
thick book
and it'd be a worse book if there were
photographs accompanying it
and you know but but i had this
advantage that
young people today don't have which was
well when my
day of stupidity was over i could go
home
and it was not there you know
like it wasn't on twitter it wasn't on
facebook
there wasn't 20 of my friends
communicating to me about
you know what foolish thing i did at the
party the night before and
um and young people now they're just
followed by paparazzi
essentially constantly and and i've
watched that with
the young teenage daughters of many of
my friends
uh because my kids were a little too old
for that to have actually have happened
to them but
god it's miserable and um we know that
there is some relationship between the
amount of time people use facebook for
example and their mental health
which me the more they use facebook the
more depressed they are
and it might be that the depression is
driving the facebook use but
the causal pathway seems to be the other
way around which is
you know it's just playing that
unbelievably exposed social game
that's hard on people and these aren't
trivial technologies you know
i mean they're sha they're they're
transforming the way we communicate with
one another and that's
and they're they're completely
uncontrolled experiments we have no idea
what the
medium or long-term consequences are
going to be and we'll never find out
either because
of course the communication landscape
changes so quickly that
by the time you get adapted to one
communication technology another one has
come along
that's even more confusing that you now
have to master
and so well that's why it's necessary
for everyone to develop their own
modicum of wisdom
i believe because i don't know how else
we're going to be able to deal with this
technological transformation that's
going to come acro
is already coming across us like a tidal
wave and you know you ain't seen nothing
yet
the other people in silicon valley have
plans that
well that that make you think that the
whole place should probably be bombed
just for the safety of the rest of us
you know because there's there's
tremendous danger in that
rapid acceleration of machine
intelligence and and
we have no we have absolutely no idea
where that's headed
so and maybe it'll be great it's it's
possible it'll be great
but power cuts both ways
so hopefully we can we can
control it with our wisdom and that's
pretty much up to each of you
to put your lives together so you can
make good decisions
so let me let me ask you this question
this is more for myself this is uh
maybe the audience who can process it
any way they want you know we started a
company
uh based on a vision of capitalism and i
promised myself i'm going to be talking
about this for the rest of my life on me
coming here from iran and
understanding how this system works and
why so many immigrants come here so i
said for the rest of our careers we're
going to be talking about this and we're
multicultural we got a lot of different
nationalities
and and that's 54 latino i think the
second largest
population in this room is probably
african-american and then it's going to
be
caucasian and then it's going to be i
can't
let out my uh my filipino community that
we have here as well
and then we got a handful of middle
easterns here as well a few hundred
middle easterns
but here's my question for you here's my
bob i want everybody to hear
i i actually don't have a clue what he's
gonna say but i'm very curious
i don't know for me
over the years i like to ask birthdays
when your birthdays to me just and i
stored in my mind i said boom is there
any kind of
correlation between these and it's not
even horoscope it's just purely a date
to me it's not like oh you're libra
you're this i go through dates right
and then the next thing i do when i
start asking people questions is if
they're like
math or they don't like math so
one time we're sitting there we're
having a debate politically about
capitalism and economy and how money
works and all this other stuff
and this one person was absolutely
against capitalism okay
it's like oh my gosh this whole capital
some stuff it's you know who cares about
the money and who cares about this and i
said let me ask you a question were you
were you somebody that liked math
growing up
i hated math is it interesting okay
very interesting that you hated matt do
you think
some of us are born with liberal
wiring and some of us are born with
conservative
wiring so it's 40 40. so i've got three
kids and they're all different from day
one they've all been different right
40 40 and then there's a 20 in the
middle that's kind of trying to figure
out
let me see which argument makes more
sense okay this makes sense okay cool
i think this makes sense because it
seems like some people no matter what
you say
they're just not going to change and
there's no way in the world if
45 whatever the numbers are democrats
and 45
are republicans let's just say you put
that number there you can't say both
sides are idiots
because one side says the other side are
idiots the other side says the other
sides are ideas i just
you can't sit there and think that it
just doesn't make you yeah well they're
both right some of the time
right so they're both right some of the
time but do you think some of the belief
system that we have politically liberal
or conservative
conservative we're born with oh yes you
you do think that oh i think the
evidence tell us tell us more tell us
why you say
well okay so there have been
good personality studies done for i
would say about 30 years
and the reason for that is that we
figured out a personality model
about 30 years ago
that's stable cross-culturally and it
was mostly derived
statistically and it required a fair bit
of computational power to
derive and basically the way that it was
derived was that
thousands of people were asked hundreds
and hundreds of questions
and then computers could figure out how
the answers grouped
so if you were likely to say yes to
question a
and also to question j um maybe
that was a tendency across a large group
of people and so you could assume that
there was something similar about
question a
and j and you could sort the questions
into groups
and it turns out that questions about
personality sort into five groups
and there's some argument about exactly
the right
number but it doesn't matter it's
somewhere between five and seven and
you can break the five down into ten but
whatever we've got a pretty good
overall descriptive structure
like the periodic table of the elements
for personality
and if you're an extrovert man it's like
you want to be where the action is you
want to be where the party is you're
you're telling jokes and you're setting
up social occasions and
and you smile a lot and you talk a lot
and you want people around you all the
time
and a tremendous amount of that is
influenced genetically and
you can tell that if you have children
because your children are like that from
like damn
about it yeah my son's quite extroverted
um well my daughter is as well but you
know he was a flirt when he was nine
months old it was ridiculous
well it was ridiculous my wife used to
pack him along on her back on one of
those little i would do the same thing
on one of those little uh you know those
little baby carriers
and i can remember one time we were on a
cruise ship
um just taking a small cruise from maine
to to nova scotia
and we got on the on the on the
boat and we were wandering through a
group of people it was like it was like
being with a rock star because he was
sitting in the back
of the little baby holder smiling away
you know like
flirting like mad and waving at everyone
and
and that that was there right at nine
months and
so people different extroversion and
that's positive emotion they differ in
neuroticism and that's negative emotion
some people are much more sensitive to
depression and grief and anxiety
their threshold for threat is a lot
lower some people are agreeable
rather than disagreeable and agreeable
people are very empathic
and self-sacrificing and the empathic
part is good because
you know it's useful to be empathic
especially if you're caring for people
who are in real trouble
but the self-sacrificing isn't so good
that can make you resentful and
and also um decrease the probability
that you're going to be successful in
your
salary negotiations and so forth so
those of you who are agreeable
and have a hard time standing up for
yourself and fighting you know you'll
fight for other people but not for
yourself
it's a very good skill to develop that
ability to
watch your resentment and see what you
need
and then make a case for it it's a hard
thing to learn
people different conscientiousness
that's orderliness and industrious and
the different creativity which is
openness
and so and a lot of that's genetic
it's there to begin with now you can
move that with the environment you know
but
but you know you have a character it's
there
liberals are higher in openness
that's trait creativity and lower in
conscientiousness
especially orderliness and that seems to
be because
they believe or their their their
let's say their niche is an
informational niche
they believe that the free flow of
information
is worth the risk so that'd be the free
flow of people across
borders the free flow of ideas across
borders the
the free flow of concepts across
categories
they'd rather that the borders were
permeable
now the conservatives are low in
openness and high in conscientiousness
especially orderliness and they take the
opposite
attack they think well yeah
there's danger in too much openness
there's danger in
borders that are too permeable things
can change too fast entire societies can
become destabilized
and everyone can end up not knowing
which way is up
and the thing is is that both of those
attitudes are correct
it depends on the time because sometimes
you know sometimes things are changing
so fast that everybody's
knocked off their feet and and things
are falling apart
and sometimes think things are so rigid
that there isn't any
new water flowing and and everything's
ground to halt you see that in
corporations very often
um where they get ossified you know and
there's no new ideas and then they
collapse
you know the average fortune 500 company
only lasts i think now it's only 24
years
and and the duration of their
occupation of the top fortune 500 space
is getting shorter and shorter every
year
you need liberals because now and then
the right thing to do is to come up with
something new and you need conservatives
because now and then the right thing to
do is to do what everybody has always
done
and the reason you need political
dialogue is so that the liberals and the
conservatives can continue to argue
about
which of those solutions is appropriate
right now
and that's powerful jordan
and that's a unifying message by the way
that's a unifying message that you're
not here yes
today it's not a unifying message that
we need each other today it's more we're
smart you're dumb and
you have no clue what you're talking
about and you're trying to take
advantage of it yeah yeah versus hey we
need to kind of process it no it's
really a bad idea you know
like it's a really bad idea because
here's another example
so you know silicon valley tends to be
liberal every everyone knows that and
the reason for that is that there's a
tremendous number of entrepreneurs there
and entrepreneurs tend to be high in
openness and lower in conscientiousness
so they're creative
but they're also willing to break rules
you know which you kind of have to do
often hopefully not to a criminal extent
but you have to
well you know it's tricky when you're
trying to establish something new
because
look at a company like uber you know
they had to bend the rules to to be
successful and those companies that have
rented those scooters out and put them
on the streets everywhere you know they
just
kind of went ahead and did it it's not
something an orderly person would do
because they'd ask for permission
whereas the people who started these
scooter rental companies just said well
what'll happen if we put them everywhere
and the answer was that seemed to work
but
you know you have to have a
rule-breaking proclivity
in order to manage that but the thing is
if you're an entrepreneur
you need conservative people because
once you've figured out how to do
something
and then you want to run it
algorithmically you know you want to run
it by the rules
well then it's the conservative types
that are going to be really good at
doing that and making sure that the eyes
are dotted and the t's are crossed and
and show up for work on time and have
stable marriages and be reliable
and their their problem is it's easy for
them to get stuck in a rut
so so this is also
rule nine which is you know attend to
the person you listen to as if they
might know something you don't
it's like i really find it interesting
to talk to people whose political
opinions differ from mine and for me
that's mostly meant
talking to really uh strong
conservatives because
i would say temperamentally i tilt in
the liberal direction although being a
social scientist has made me
more conservative it's very interesting
to talk to people who don't share your
political views
if you listen to them because they'll
tell you all sorts of things about why
they think that you just don't
understand
and it's not that they're wrong it's
that
sometimes they're wrong and sometimes
they're right and
the the whole point of free speech as
far as i can tell the deep point of free
speech is that
you know it's all as if we're riding on
the back of a giant snake and it it's
twisting and turning
all the time and we're trying to figure
out how to stay in the center
so that we don't fall off the sides you
know and
sometimes it's time for a bit of a tilt
to the left and sometimes it's a bit
time for a bit of a tilt to the right
and the only way you can tell when
that time is is by having a discussion
about it
and it's so it's the discussion that
keeps the
that keeps us centered it's not the fact
that the conservatives are right or that
the liberals are right
they're both necessary annoying as that
is
so so so let me ask you this let me ask
you this
to follow up on that so
is there is there such a thing
because so i sit there and i listen to
somebody i was at the
wayne hughes house and when he's had a
bill clinton's campaign manager and when
he said george bush's campaign manager
right
it's only 40 of us and this is like 10
years ago and they're both debating
on their argument both very convincing
okay they're both very
convincing and persuasive
is there such a thing as a hundred
percent truth
or is truth always adapting because if
what you're saying is it's opinions
listen to both opinions and see what
makes sense and what doesn't make sense
versus is there something that i can
look for that gets my argument a point
to say you know what this
is the accurate 100 truth i'm gonna
solve it based on this because in math
three times three is nine
i don't need a liberal conservative
libertarian conservative you know
whoever it is to tell me right three
times three is math
is there that as well to look at
arguments and say this is the truth
based on this or are we are having to
still be a little bit nimble to see what
both arguments are well
i would say two things about that is one
is
i think there are times when you can
establish truths
this is one of the reasons i like bjorn
lomberg's work he wrote a book called
how to spend 75 billion dollars to make
the world a better place
and what he did was put together these
10 teams of economists
he had them rank order the problems in
terms of return on investment
and then he averaged across their
estimates and came up with a final list
you know that that's not a bad
application of the search
for uh objective truth in the political
and social domain
so and it's relatively apolitical right
because
the economists he gathered variety of
different political beliefs and
um and so so i think there are times
when there are objective facts
that present themselves in the political
sphere but most of the time political
discussion is more
it's more like marital negotiation you
know and
it's right it's it's right when it works
in the world that would be the first
thing like let's say you have a plan
and you implement the plan and the plan
turns out the way that you expected it
to it's a pragmatic
definition of truth okay that plan
flawed no doubt it that it was imperfect
no doubt that it was was accurate enough
so that when you implemented it
it justified its own structure and
that's a lot of the way we judge truth
in the world right
you you think you're right if you do
something and it works and
that doesn't mean you're 100 right and
it doesn't mean it's going to work
forever but
because you're ignorant and because your
knowledge is limited that's kind of what
you've got
and so that's one form of truth and then
another form is
well can we agree in a negotiated manner
like we kind of hope that if we're
trying to solve a problem that we can
talk until
we come up with the least bad
alternative that both of us can live
with
is that that's not the truth though
we're compromising right and maybe your
idea is better than my idea i'm not
you know what i'm saying so let's just
say your idea is better than my idea but
i'm better at convincing you than you
are convincing me that doesn't mean the
best idea is being implemented right
oh that happens all the time there's
lots of times when the best idea doesn't
win
right you know but that's partly why the
fact that we're constrained by the world
is helpful
i mean what you want to do in politics
you know what i'm saying like what i'm
trying to say is like
so i want to know is there a formula to
get to the truth so then i can say
this is where i stand on this position
or is it all about
a lot of going back and forth and
discord until i'm kind of like
okay i kind of relate to this 100
truth versus 70 80 percent
you see you know what i'm what i'm
saying i think 100 truths are very
difficult to come by that's where i'm
going with you know okay
i mean i've been trying to identify
hundred percent
truths the the hundred percent truths
let's say that sit at the bottom of our
societies and
one of the things that i believe to be
true is that the idea that the
individual is
properly sovereign i believe is as true
as any idea that human beings have ever
come up with i think that that idea
works
um not everyone would agree with that
the more complex the situation the
harder it is to
extract out something approximating an
objective truth
and and and so then so much of it
depends on
negotiation and discussion and and
agreement now there there are ways of
of addressing that as well you know one
of the reasons that
the united states works so nicely um
compared to many other countries is that
well you have
a plethora of states and each of those
states
in some sense is an experiment and all
of the sub
structures of those states are
experiments and you know you
because you have so many experiments
going on which is also one of the
advantages of an open society
is you can kind of observe and see with
all these
solutions being generated which ones
seem to be efficient and effective
and so one of the ways that you come up
with truth
from the political level is essentially
through a darwinian process you know if
you really want to solve a
complicated problem maybe you try to
solve it 100 ways
and then you take the best solution got
it and look this happens to
entrepreneurs all the time too you know
like most entrepreneurs
this is something to know well most
entrepreneurs most creative people
fail at producing their creative product
and monetizing it
right so your default position if you're
a creative person is you're going to
fail
and so and that's because it's hard to
come up with something new and it's
j and it's hard to present it to the
market
at the right time and it's hard to
market it
like those things are really really
difficult and so what successful
entrepreneurs do is they just keep doing
it
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and eventually
if they're fortunate one of their ideas
happens to hit
the right place at the right time and so
that's also
darwinian in some sense you know you're
creating all these little enterprises
that are sort of alive
they're they're run by people after all
and even if your idea is good that
doesn't mean it will be successful
there's so many things that have to be
taken into account so
this is partly why persistence and
that's part of conscientiousness is so
useful it's like
you know what do they say if at first
you failed then try try again and
um and that would probably mean try
something different rather than the same
thing
but persistence is helpful because it
enables you to run many many experiments
and
and you need to know that the baseline
is failure you know it's important
because otherwise
you'll blame that on yourself you know
and
some of that's useful because there's
probably some things that you could
improve about yourself but
it's very difficult to go from zero to
one
you know it's very if you're starting
out as a sales person for example the
hardest sale is the first customer
and then you know they get easier with
each additional customer but so question
last question for you before we wrap up
last question before we wrap up is
um so say i see somebody in the room
here hypothetically and i said oh my
gosh i would love to
you know have that kind of a life i'd
love to make that kind of money
right and i compare myself to them right
oh my gosh what if one day i can be that
person what if one day i can have that
life right
how do i go from there to actually
wanting to live it
and become a reality versus not allowing
nbn resentment
pin me against them kind of like you
know kane wanted to be able but he
couldn't so he goes and
you know kills abel how do you how do
you manage that
well the first thing i think you need to
understand is that
these people that you're comparing
yourself to you don't really know
very well you know and
um
what that means is that you see they're
shiny outside but you don't see the
reality of their life
and so what you're
you know maybe you're in california see
someone speeding down the road in a
in a convertible portion you think oh
man what a lucky bastard and
um the truth of the matter is that he's
thinking about wrapping his
expensive sports car around the next
cement pillar that he comes
close to you know you can't tell and
people have hard lives
and and even people who are
comparatively fortunate have hard lives
and
so the the ideal
that you're observing that makes you
jealous and resentful
is in large part an illusion that's
created by your own mind
and i
you know i i can give you just one
example is like i know a fair number of
extremely wealthy people and
um most of them most of the people i
happen to know are people who've made
them
their money themselves and i tell you
man they have a burden of responsibility
that
would would crush me would
would crush the typical person they're
just working
flat out like 90 hours a week
and they have thousands of people
depending on them and you know they have
their money
and and they have their status and
that's not nothing
but don't be thinking that there isn't a
price to be paid for that you know they
don't see their families they're often
divorced they don't see their children
grow up
and and they don't have time off now
there are wealthy
what would you call playboy types i
suppose who
live out the dreams of wealth of a
foolish 14 year old but
they're not that common and you have to
be careful of what you're jealous of
because you don't really know what it is
and then the other thing that's kind of
useful is to
well to understand that you're different
from everyone else and
this is especially true as you get older
when when you're 17 or 16 or something
like that
comparing yourself to other people makes
a certain amount of sense because
16 and 17 year olds they're kind of the
same you know which is why
when you go off to university you can
make friends so quickly it's like
i'm i'm just about 60. it takes me like
15 years
to make a friend now you know um
as opposed to the two months that it
took when i was 17.
um you're you're quite different from
other people and
you shouldn't be comparing yourself to
them because they're not like you
you know they don't have your family
they don't have your temperament they
don't have your troubles
they don't have your abilities the only
person that
the only the only person that has those
is you
and this is why one of the rules i think
it's rule four
is compare yourself to who you were
yesterday and not to who someone else is
today
and see that's a game you can win
because
you could be a little better today than
you were yesterday
and that's a good thing you're a little
better that that's a good thing and
you know no doubt there are some things
that you could improve you know if you
if you sit and meditate for any length
of time about
what you're not doing optimally answers
will spring to mind you know you could
be getting up earlier you could be
you could be you could be watching
youtube less unless they're my videos in
which case you could be watching them
more
um
anyways can't believe i said that
actually i actually can't believe i said
that
that's the entrepreneur's side of you
but like comparing yourself to who you
are now that's a game you can win
and like i've seen this be effective in
many many cases in my clinical practice
for example it's like you take stock of
where you are
you know what your advantages are what
your disadvantages are and then
you start with a little humility on the
path
of incremental improvement and you know
incremental improvement
compounds and so you can get a long ways
and
and then it's you see because trajectory
in some sense is more important than
position
for for human beings i mean if you're
starving to death
and deal that's not the situation that
i'm describing but you know if you've
got the bare necessities of life and so
you're not
you're not surrounded by absolute
privation what you really want is to see
that you're on an uphill path you know
something that's got the right slope and
and and you can start anywhere
on that path and you you can improve
half a percent a day or a quarter of a
percent a day and you think well that's
not very much it's like
it's a hundred percent if it's a quarter
percent a day
it's a hundred percent in four years and
that doesn't count compounding
you know which means it's actually going
to happen a lot faster
and that's duplicatable anybody can do
that anybody can do that it's not just
applicable to the most talented person
or the leader no
anybody i think that the possibility
that you can
make yourself slightly better on a
continual basis is
i think that's something that's
accessible to everyone i i think that's
equivalent to leading a virtuous life
and
you know i talked about the terrible
catastrophe in some sense of differences
in intelligence and differences in
conscientiousness and so forth and
the the downside of the meritocracy but
there is something to be said for virtue
and truth you know and that is one thing
another thing that i've noticed about
people who've been phenomenally
successful is that
they really do they really do everything
they can to live a truthful life
and that you can get a bloody long ways
by being
honest it's really something and so
you know what uh um one of the things i
want he's talking about you never know
what people are going through myself
marvin and jordan were speaking
backstage
and uh you know he's been not as
active recently as possible with media
because of what your
uh personal life what your wife is going
through health wise and he still kept
his commitment to
come out he have so much respect for
someone like jordan peterson to still
keep his commitment and that's tough to
do
it's your wife so let's make some noise
for jordan peterson
jordan appreciation for coming up
you